bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public à senna quelles sont les
difficultés rencontrées par les élus
locaux face à la complexité croissante
de l'application des lois voir aline
application de certains textes votés par
le parlement
éléments de réponse cet après midi avec
ce forum organisé par le président de la
commission d'application des lois le
sénateur socialiste de paris david
assouline bel après midi à tous bien je
propose que nous commencions en sachant
que les sénateurs qui ont tous été
invités
7 ce forum cette séance de travail des
bons bien sont dans des commissions sur
le fou le mardi après midi
souvent mais en même temps c'est le
moment où on peut tous les capter donc
qui je pense qu'ils vont arriver au fur
et à mesure de deux parce que je sais
que la question que nous allons aborder
est attendu en tous les cas intéresse
tous mes collègues qui je peux discuter
elle et elle et elle va être traités par
des éminentes personnalités c'est ça
l'essentiel
de toute façon la publication des actes
de ce forum
l'enregistrement je vous préviens que
tout est enregistré en vidéo et sera sur
le site du scénar et la publicité sera
fait de tout ce qui pourrait d'ici en
tous les cas on a voulu
d'abord je vais citer une des
personnalités ensuite on les présentera
eu les unes après les autres femmes
besoins des interventions mais je veux
remercier encore une fois le secrétaire
général du gouvernement monsieur serge
lasvignes d'être parmi nous c'est la
troisième fois depuis la constitution de
notre commission qu'il vient qu'ils
prêtent attention à notre démarche qui
est évolutive puisque c'est nouveau
c'est ça reste encore nouveau cette
démarche le contrôle de l'application
des lois
c'est quelque chose qui va falloir faire
rentrer presque culturellement dans le
travail parlementaire dans notre pays et
on est que vraiment à l'aube
en tous les cas même si il ya eu des
choses de faites depuis quelques
décennies
je considère qu on est encore à l'aube
j'ai souvent eu l'occasion de le dire
l'application des lois est beaucoup plus
qu'une question de technique juridique
c'est un véritable enjeu de démocratie
comme tel ce comme tel ce thème
intéresse non seulement les
parlementaires et le gouvernement mais
aussi les élus locaux et d'une manière
plus générale les usagers du droit
souvent désarmés face à la prolifération
des textes ou des circulaires c'est
pourquoi il m'a semblé utile de réunir
un panel d'experts de praticiens qui
vont nous donner tour à tour différents
points de vue sur cette question plutôt
qu'une succession d'audition on aurait
pu faire comme ça et on le fait souvent
j'ai préféré la forme d'une table ronde
qui permet quelque chose de plus vivant
et et voir d'interactif entre entre les
problématiques soulevées et les
différents intervenants
cela va supposer bien sûr un peu de
discipline dans le respect des temps de
parole je vous en remercie par avance
pour la fluidité de nos débats j'ai fait
distribuer un dérouleur qui doit être
normalement donné à tout le monde
organisant la table ronde en trois
séquences la première le point de vue
des usagers de la norme et on entendra
donc sur cette partie là monsieur didier
mathus qu au nom des maires maire de
montceau les mines membres du bureau de
l'association des maires de france
ensuite les bâtonniers la batelière
maître dominique païenne de la grade de
la garanderie ancienne bâtonnière
bernard watier et à ma droite ancien
bâtonnier des avocats au barreau de
paris
et puis questions et réactions des
sénateurs et des autres intervenants sur
cet aspect là c'est à dire le point de
vue des usagers de la norme la deuxième
séquence la problématique juridique
monsieur guy carcassonne ma gauche
professeur de droit public à
l'université de paris ouest nanterre la
défense
madame céline kaufmann qui économiste à
l'organisation de coopération et de
développement économiques ocde est
pareil questions-réponses interactivité
entre les sénateurs présents et les
participants à la table et la dernière
séquence la réaction des producteurs de
normes et là monsieur didier lallement
préfet voulait un préfet à l'honneur
d'avoir en même temps le secrétaire
général du ministère de l'intérieur
monsieur serge lasvignes secrétaire
général du gouvernement donc a été au
sommet on va dire de ce que l'on pouvait
avoir pour animer ce moment sur la
réaction des producteurs de normes et
puis ensuite une
discussion générale limitée discussion
générale sur l'ensemble de ce qui aura
pu émerger de est propre aux savants et
intéressant que nous allons avoir dès
maintenant donc je passe tout de suite
la parole pour la première séquence le
point de vue des usagers de la norme à
monsieur didier mathus
merci monsieur le président mais des
propos ils étaient préparés peut-être
avant mais il ya deux questions que
j'aimerais voir traiter les maires sont
submergés de textes et sont ainsi les
premières victimes de l'inflation
normative même s'ils sont pas que des
victimes bien sûr notamment ceux des
petites communes des moins bien armé
pour y faire face la mef at elle adopté
une position officielle ou des
préconisations sur cette question et
puis vous êtes député maire jusqu'en
vous avez été député maire jusqu'en 2012
vous avez évolué donc aux deux
extrémités de la chaîne de production
normative chargé d'écrire la loi au
parlement est chargée de l'appliquer
dans votre commune
quels enseignements tirez-vous de ce
dédoublement de personnalité
législatives
merci monsieur le président donc je vais
être bref dix minutes
vous l'avez souligné effectivement g
dans l'existence eu l'occasion donc de
voir comment on écrivait la loi et de
l'autre côté comment elle était
appliquée comme on la ressentait dans
les communes aujourd'hui je m'exprime au
nom de la mf donc qui depuis plusieurs
années a sonné l alerte d'une certaine
façon sur l'inflation normative cette
marée montante de textes législatifs
réglementaires on ne sait plus toujours
d'ailleurs qui ont pris une importance
et financière et est concrète dans
l'organisation des services parfois
sinon des jurés en tout cas extrêmement
préoccupante
c'est vrai que ce qu'on peut vivre dans
les communes dans les collectivités
d'une façon générale et parfois assez
surprenant alors j'aurais bien sûr comme
tous les maires de france mille
anecdotes racontées sur les excès de
certaines dérives normative et sur eux
cette jungle aujourd'hui qui fait que
d'ailleurs on sait plus très bien qui
produit les normes
je suis très heureux de savoir qu'on est
à côté des plus grands producteurs de
norne n'est plus en tout cas les plus
experts ici ça va être intéressant parce
que ce que j'observe c'est que ayant été
député je vois bien que beaucoup de ces
normes sont de nature plutôt
réglementaire et que leur base
législative paraît assez ténue on nous
explique toujours que c'est au nom de la
loi que on décline un certain nombre de
textes d'application mais quand on
creuse un peu on s'aperçoit que encore
une fois la base législative et est
assez fragile ce que j'ai pu observer ce
qu'il ya des lois dont l'impact
financier n'est pas manifestement
calibrer au moment où les votes où on
les écrit on les votes
en tout le monde en tête la loi de 2005
généreuse et légitime dans son principe
sur les handicapés mais concrètement
quasi un déclinable dans la réalité des
choses pour 2015 puisque c'est
l'échéance qui étaient fixés parce que
dans n'importe quelle commune qui se
trouvent confrontés à des équipements
qui vont nécessiter des millions d'euros
parfois une petite ville vingt mille
habitants c'est deux millions et demi
d'euros
deux millions et demi d'euros c'est
compliqué de les trouver quoi donc
il ya des lois qui manifestement ne sont
pas justement calibrer au moment de leur
adoption
il ya beaucoup de lois qui sont trop
imprécises qui souvent empiètent sur le
domaine réglementaire et on pourrait
d'ailleurs s'interroger je suppose que
tous les parlementaires le fond sur la
manière que nous avons décrire la loi
qui est parfois j'ai le sentiment que on
ne s'est pas améliorée dans ce domaine
et que au fil des décennies la qualité
d'écriture de la loi s'est plutôt
dégradée et que ce qui devrait rester du
domaine de la loi c'est-à-dire l'énoncé
des guides ses rangs le grand principe a
souvent été un peu perverti dans des
déclinaisons beaucoup trop précises qui
rendent ensuite leurs applications
d'ailleurs extrêmement délicate alors on
a tous en tête des tas d'exemples moi je
suis amené à m'interroger sur
l'évolution de ces normes pour savoir au
fond est ce qu'elles ont cyrville bien
public et j'en suis pas convaincu parce
que au fond d'eux de malheur dans ce
pays c'est furiani
la première fois un préfet étaient
traduits devant des instances
judiciaires qui fait que immédiatement
après une sur deux cultures nouvelles
s'est emparé ce sens que didier
lallement va pas être de mon avis mais
culture nouvelle s'est emparé du corps
préfectoral consistant à ouvrir les
parapluies à la moindre moindre alerte
et de chaîne en chaîne dur de du haut de
l'échelle jusqu'en bas il ya eu une
sorte de réflexe qui s'est instaurée
consistant à se couvrir mécaniquement
deuxième autre principe qui a quand même
eu des répercussions qui ne sont pas
toutes positives c'est le principe de
précaution puisque on est le seul pays à
avoir inscrit ce principe de précaution
fronton notre constitution
alors je lisais ce matin dans la presse
que la publication des patrimoines des
ministres s'était forcément bien puisque
tous les autres le faisait on pourrait
s'interroger est ce que quand on est les
seuls à faire les deux choses est-ce que
c'est forcément bien aussi puisque le
principe de précaution ma connaissance
on est le seul pays au monde à avoir
inscrit ça dans notre constitution avec
des déclinaisons qui évidemment à partir
de l'énoncé d'un principe encore une
fois sûrement généreux mais qui peut
prêter à mille interprétations
différentes et donc on est envahi par
cette cette inflation normative qui
rendent encore une fois les choses très
difficiles et je disais on peut
s'interroger sur l'utilité en termes
d'intérêt général de certaines de ces
normes je prends un tout petit exemple
mais bon qui m'a beaucoup frappé j'ai
été député pendant 25 ans j'avais donc
une circonscription avec 70 communes
dont beaucoup de petites communes
rurales au début où j'ai été député
quand je visitais des communes par
exemple il ya des cantines scolaires
avec des dames qui faisait la cantine et
qui prenait soin de leurs enfants
n'étaient pas très nombreux en général
ils étaient une douzaine à manger à la
petite cantine elle savait ce que ce
qu'ils aimaient ce qu'il n'aimait pas le
prenez soin d'eux et puis petit à petit
la direction des services vétérinaires
s'est occupé de ce dossier et donc on a
petit à petit en gros interdit à toutes
ces communes de continuer de la sorte au
nom bien sûr de l'hygiène alimentaire de
la sécurité alimentaire
je me souviens d'une chose qui m'avait
frappé c'était une petite cantine qu'on
a fait fermer parce que le placard à
balais était à moins de jus combien
trois mètres ou 4 m 2
des cuisinières donc moi j'ai vu au fil
des années l'action publique à travers
celle de la dsv du département qui peu à
peu a fait fermer toutes ses petites
cantines scolaires qui était au fond des
exemples avant l'heure des circuits
courts qu'on met en gloire maintenant et
qu'ils ont livrée l'alimentation de tous
ses enfants aux industriels de
l'agroalimentaire puis si on touche
passé en liaison froide la sodexo je ne
sais quoi
donc on peut se demander dans ce cas là
si l'édiction de normes et l'action
publique de l'état à travers un de ses
services a été un bien pour ses enfants
et pour les communes j avais aussi un
réseau économique qui vivaient autour de
tout ça qui a disparu bien sûr
donc ça c'est qu'un exemple mais il est
assez frappant le deuxième exemple que
je vais prendre il est tout récent parce
que je suis presque traumatisé par sa
c'est je construis chez moi passerait le
handicapé pour accéder à l'église alors
dans un premier temps mais expliquer
qu'on pouvait pas faire une entrée sur
le petit côté qui était plus facile à
faire qui les prenaient pas beaucoup de
place parce que c'était de la
discrimination très bien d'accord j'en
prends acte et donc qu'il fallait faire
une passerelle qui aboutissent à la
grande entrée de l'église qui est qu'il
ya un dénivelé beaucoup plus important
et puis on m'a expliqué aussi qu'il
fallait que deux fauteuils puissent se
croiser au cas où ce qui me paraît assez
peu probable compte tenu la
fréquentation de l'église
enfin bon et donc je me retrouve avec le
pont de tancarville à peu près pour
accéder à l'église maintenant donc ça et
on me dit ah mais non mais les services
me disant on peut pas faire autrement
c'est énorme on est obligés sinon
ce faire discuter par le préfet etc donc
je trouve qu'on arrive à des situations
vraiment très paradoxal mais vous verrez
tout ça dans le rapport
boulard lambert qui est très instructif
bien fait plutôt agréable à lire
d'ailleurs avec des petites histoires et
des illustrations et qui reflète je
crois l'état d'esprit les maires
regroupés à la mf c'est un sujet que
nous évoquons régulièrement vous savez
qu'on a saisi encore une fois le pouvoir
exécutif de cette affaire qu'un certain
nombre de décisions ont été prises avec
l'idée du shop de simplification et de
toute une série de mesures qui devraient
être décliné dans les mois qui viennent
mais je crois que on a tendance à ne pas
mesurer à quel point la société
française aujourd'hui à travers ces
collectivités essentiellement est en
partie étouffé par ses contraintes qui
s'accumulent qui s'accumulent au fil du
temps et qui deviennent quasi ingérable
pour un bon nombre de communes ingérable
d'abord techniquement c'est vrai en
particulier des petites communes mais
pas seulement pour eux les communes
importantes c'est aussi un problème et
est ingérable financièrement parce qu on
a tellement multiplier les coûts liés à
ces contraintes que on a des difficultés
budgétaires surtout dans le contexte
nouveau que nous connaissons de décrue
des finances locales donc je crois que
c'est un grand sujet la mf on a fait
effectivement d un des points importants
de son débat permanent avec l'exécutif
parce que les enjeux qui sont derrière
évidemment on l'est on les voit très
bien je vois que j'arrive au bout de mes
dix minutes donc je m'en tiens là merci
merci et dim et us où le temps est
respectée en tous les cas où vous
exprimer quelque chose courante en
tellement souvent que même par des
exemples c'est un propos très très
quelqu'un alors aussi général et
et qui est qu'il faut entendre
concrètement dans la pratique de votre
profession monsieur vous avez déjà eu à
traiter les affaires où le contentieux
était directement lié à
l'inapplicabilité d'une loi ou d'un
décret dans l'ensemble votre pratique
vous confronte elle souvent à des
problèmes de discordance entre la
volonté du désastre et heures telle
qu'elle est exprimée dans la loi et la
mise en oeuvre qui en est faite par les
règlements les circulaires d'application
donc vous allez nous vous répondrons
aussi à ça y est aussi ce que vous
voulez a ajouté madame permettez moi de
répondre soit un petit peu différente
dans la mesure où les classes qui à
certains textes qui sont rédigées
peut-être hâtivement et qui peuvent qui
peuvent poser problème je prends cela
très précisément la loi de finances qui
modifient chaque année les cotisations
de sécurité sociale en fonction des
indemnités qui seront versées dans les
ruptures des contrats il a fallu toutes
les fois une circulaire les circulaires
ne reprennent pas d'une année sur
l'autre les mêmes dispositions et par
conséquent lorsque nous sommes consultés
au niveau des praticiens nous avons déjà
beaucoup de mal à expliquer ce qu'il
faut faire pour être sûr de ne pas se
tromper
quant aux juridictions il y a là un
questionnement qui nous permet de
constater actuellement qu'il n'y a
évidemment aucune cohérence dans les
réponses
alors là c'est la technique législative
peut-être qui est en cause je ne sais
pas ce que je sais c'est que certains
textes qui sont visés nous pose problème
parce qu'ils ne correspondent pas ce qui
doit être
ce qui veux tu être dit et sur des
textes comme ceux là vraiment je vous
importez monsieur le président les
tableaux que nous sommes obligés de
faire pour comprendre ce qui se passe
depuis 2011
dans cette matière là je transmettais
vous vous verrez
les chevaux et joie la dernière
circulaire vous verrez à quoi nous
sommes confrontés alors plus de façon
plus complète j'exprimerai les
difficultés que nous avons dans la
relation entre la loi telle qu'elle est
rédigée par le législateur est livrée
par lui et l'application qui en est
faite par les juridictions
chaque chaque position est évidemment
respectable sauf que nous avons des
textes qui sont apparemment clair et qui
donne et qui font l'objet d'une
jurisprudence qui je dois le dire peut
tout de même mettre en cause la sécurité
juridique
je donnerai trois exemples le premier
exemple concerne la nullité des
procédures de licenciement économique
je le dis comme ça alors que votre texte
est particulièrement clair il a été fait
à plusieurs reprises la première mouture
était la nullité des plans sociaux
s'il n'était pas convenablement présenté
il avait été dit je fais un point
d'histoire il avait avait été rope
repoussé un amendement du parti
communiste qui voulaient étendre cette
nullité à des nullités des licenciements
nonobstant le la proposition communiste
et ce rejet
la jurisprudence a avec l'arrêt
samaritaine qui n'est pas tout neuf mais
keynes n'a jamais été démentie considéré
qu'il y avait pour conséquence et parce
que c'était subséquents c'est la théorie
juridique la nullité des licenciements
ce qui m'a beaucoup préoccupé à l'époque
c'est que l'intention du législateur
avait été très clairement discuter au
parlement et que nous avons plaidé sur
l'attention du législateur sans être
plus entendue
vous avez donc rédiger un nouveau texte
qui est on ne peut plus claire qui vise
le plan de reclassement des salariés si
celui-là n'est pas fait à l'occasion du
pse et bien
il n'y a pas le plan de reclassement des
salariés alors là le plan nuls et il n'y
aura pas de licenciements donc ça ne
sera pas fait c'est clair la nouvelle
l'oise
c'est la nouvelle loi elle est
parfaitement clair sénat demain elle est
parfaitement clair il n'empêche que la
jurisprudence sur la nullité des
licenciements persiste et par une autre
entrée cette fois ci ce ne sont pas les
mesures de protection des salariés dans
les reclassements qui sont mises en
études mais le motif est que de wicked
d'euros contre votre texte pour aboutir
à des licenciements
encore une fois toutes les positions
sont respectables
ce qui nous préoccupe c'est que là
l'intention du législateur n'est pas
recherché et il ne me semble pas que sur
des taxes qui sont aussi précis et qui
ont été réécrits à plusieurs reprises il
y ait la possibilité de ce genre
d'interprétation deuxième exemple les
délais vous avez pris des dispositions
aussi pour indiquer que s'il y avait
lieu de se plaindre d'un licenciement
économique et de saisir la justice il y
avait un délai de 12 mois lorsqu'il
était encore en cause la régularité et
la validité du licenciement
il me semblait que c'était parfaitement
claire aussi
la jurisprudence considère que s'il n'y
a pas de motif économique c'est-à-dire
le licenciement n'est pas la lame c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de cause réelle et
sérieuse de licenciement bascule sur
autre chose
et puisqu'il n'y a pas de cause réelle
et sérieuse de licenciement
il n'y a pas lieu à respecter le délai
de 12 mois
troisième exemple les reclassement du
salarié inapte vous avez mis en place
une législation qui est contraignante
mais parfaitement justifié faut bien le
reconnaître de salarié inapte je ne
parle pas là des accidents du travail et
des maladies professionnelles
on peut penser à des salariés qui seront
atteints d'un cancer ou d'une hémiplégie
ils sont reçus par le médecin du travail
bien entendu qu'il est déclaré inapte
l'employeur n'a pas la possibilité d'en
tirer tout de suite les conséquences il
faut qu'ils reclasse le salarié qui par
nature est inapte donc il ya une demande
écrite à l'inspecteur du travail qui
confirme l'inaptitude et bien la
jurisprudence considère qu'il ya lieu de
condamner à des dommages d'intérêts
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de proposition
dans l'ensemble des sociétés du groupe
de reclassement du salarié
donc nous sommes là devant des
situations qui sont extrêmement
préoccupantes car c'est évidemment un
faisable pour l'employeur et on voit
bien encore une fois ça peut paraître
extrêmement légitime que le but est de
l'indemniser mieux ces salariés qui vont
évidemment tout perdre et la loi a déjà
prévu de doubler les indemnités de
licenciement si ça n'est pas suffisant
peut-être faudrait-il que le législateur
s'en emparent pour fixer un montant
qu'ils puissent être prévu provisionner
et compris mais qu' on ne demande pas
l'absurde à un employeur c'est à dire de
reclasser quelqu'un qui est totalement
inapte à tout travail
nous sommes donc là je n'ai pris que
trois exemples parce que le temps est
compté
je pourrais les multiplier et je ne
voudrais pas qu'il puisse être pensé que
je mets là en cause le travail des juges
mais en revanche ce que je peux
une équation comprennent une question
pour préciser votre propos à part le
dernier cas où c'est la loi qui demande
l'impossible les autres fois vous dit la
loi est claire mais la jurisprudence à
le dire des jugements rendus
c'est ça c'est ça alors je m'attendais à
cette question vous vous dites qu'il y a
quand même un dialogue me semble-t-il
entre le législateur et le juge
par exemple il y avait un texte qui
prévoyait des modalités de de
consultation dans le cadre de
modification substantielle du contrat de
travail c'était au terme substantielle
du contrat de travail et une procédure
qui s'apparentait à un peu la lourdeur
des licenciements économiques
la jurisprudence a considéré que
substantielles ça avait une
signification trop lourdes et trop
contraignante et restrictive et a donc
ouvert à une modification essentielle et
bien la jurisprudence a été at on
entendu vous avez modifié le texte et
vous avez repris la notion d' essentiel
donc ma question est la suivante à
partir du moment où il ya une règle qui
semble clair et qui assure une sécurité
juridique yati que peut-on faire pour
éviter qu'il y ait une interprétation
qui devient la création d'une règle de
droit la cour de cassation il ya
quelques années a longuement travaillé
sur ces questions
en considérant qu'il y avait du fait de
certaines jurisprudences la création
d'une règle de droit qui par nature
devient leur rétroactif ce qui est
évidemment contraire à notre un autre
fondement législatif et je terminerai en
disant que lorsque l'on voit ce
mouvement de jurisprudence qui crée du
droit et qui s'impose aux parties et qui
a des conséquences graves
quand on a on s'intéresse à ce mouvement
l'un ne sommes nous pas en train de
changer de système
monsieur
disait il ya un instant qu'il fallait
des lois claires précises et que ce soit
des principes nous nous rendons compte
vous l'avez compris je ne parle que de
la matière sociale que je crois
connaître un peu nous sommes là
confrontés désormais un système de
création de droit par le juge qui
s'impose aux parties et c'est peut-être
un système inspiré du système anglo
saxon mais ça n'est pas notre
constitution
monsieur le bâtonnier
mais maintenant je me garderai bien de
contredire c'est qu'avec ses errements
dit la dame de matane y est si la
problématique qui est posée en fait les
on n'est pas les avocats ne sont pas les
usagers de la justice et avocats sont
plutôt les ferronniers
ce sont eux qui appliquent les outils
législatifs et ils ont effectivement
aujourd'hui une l'impression que l'on
change de système et on a développé et
une réglementation qui est une
réglementation quasiment du comportement
qui s'impose à tous égards c'est à dire
que le la place du libre arbitre du
citoyen est de plus en plus réduites la
raison des contraintes qui sont imposés
aux dons la réglementation en général
par la loi mais je pense la
réglementation générale et cette
réglementation parce que si la
réglementation est exclusive du bon sens
parce qu'on peut arriver les situations
qui sont absurdes et néanmoins cette
réglementation a trouvé un s'imposer
parce que y'a un autre un aspect une
dominante qui émerge aujourd'hui c'est
l'aspiration du droit pénal
l'inspiration du droit pénal avec la
possibilité dans l'hypothèse d'un
accident de
renvoyé en correctionnelle celui qui n'a
pas respecté la prescription la
prescription
quand bien même rien tout à fait modeste
et minable mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que c'est une prescription et le
défaut de respect de cette prescription
peut constituer effectivement une
infraction pénale et par conséquent une
dynamique qui est un c préoccupante en
ce sens que le droit pénal n'est plus
nécessairement le droit de valdes des
valeurs ça devient une sanction à la
non-application d'un texte et cela
favorise plus encore la réglementation
sera définitif celui qui devait prendre
la réglementation de la paperie se
trouve à responsable est celui qui
devait l'appliquent il sera également
responsable en aidant dans une logique
d'une logique inflationniste qui est
effectivement préoccupant que le
deuxième point que deuxième point qui me
semble devoir être souligné c'est le
fait que aujourd'hui le le juge n'est
plus une bouche de la bouche de la loi
contrairement à ce que disait
montesquieu le juge devient lui-même
législateur et j'avais été frappé par un
arrêt qui avait été rendue en 2004 par
l'assemblée plénière de la cour de
cassation dans les circonstances
suivantes
il s'agissait de la question de
détermination du prix du loyer des
grandes surfaces et supermarchés et
l'agérie france avait modifié la
colonisation a modifié la jurisprudence
est résulté un impact te fait
appréciable dans l'économie générale des
des grandes surfaces et le législateur
est intervenu pour revenir sur la ce qui
est l application du texte précédent est
tel que l'avait fait la jurisprudence
avant le revirement et le législateur
avait pris soin de préciser que cette
loi s'appliquait aux instances en cours
pour bien montrer que c'était
l'intention du dissipateur d'origine et
la cour de cassation a rendu une
décision qui en fin d'assemblée plénière
qui révèle
si la suprématie du juge judiciaire sur
le législateur puisque sur le fond de
l'article 55 de la constitution
elle a fait prévaloir les règles de
sécurité juridique imposée par la cour
de strasbourg pour indiquer qu'une loi
ne pouvait pas être expressément
rétroactive
c'est à dire que l'on se retrouve dans
une configuration tout à fait étonnante
d'une jurisprudence c'est-à-dire d'une
norme qui va avoir une valeur attractive
qui est celle du juge
avec une puissance tout à fait
remarquable et une norme du législateur
issu de la volonté populaire qui elle
peut se trouver quand capitis diminution
cette situation et est étonnante
elle est étonnante et elle a pour
conséquence pour le praticien a pour
conséquence de créer des phénomènes
d'atteinte à la compétitivité écrit des
phénomènes de rigidité du corps social
on a aujourd'hui beaucoup de difficulté
à anticiper sur l'application d'une loi
à raison précisément de l'incertitude
dans laquelle nous serons de la
jurisprudence à venir
et compte tenu de la rétroactivité de la
jurisprudence le risque est considérable
on a par conséquent ici un élément qui
doit nous faire réfléchir sur le fait
que l'application de la loi
si la loi était appliquée sans qu'il y
ait des éléments d'imprévisibilité il
n'y aurait pas de difficultés problèmes
qu'il ya c'est que la loi n'est pas
nécessairement appliqué avec cet élément
de lisibilité et de sécurité je voudrais
ici dire que le juge n'est pas le seul
coupable voire faut dire aussi que le
parlement lui offre l'opportunité
l'offre opportunité pourquoi parce que
bien se voir des textes ne sont pas
suffisamment clair des textes par
l'effet d'une discussion parlementaire
par l'effet d'un cavalier
qui posait le texte qui avait une
configuration applicables au début
devient une source de conflits parce que
il n'y a pas eu cette étude d'impact au
moment de la mise en place de l'adoption
de ce cavalier qui pouvait tout à fait
justifiée mais on se retrouve à ce
moment là dedans une situation de 1,2
c'est le juge qui va départager et donc
on revient là encore ce que le pouvoir
du juge et je voulais dire
dernier point ce sujet on a un élément
de correction
on a un élément de correction qui
apparaît aujourd'hui qui est la qpc
parce que le la loi la loi à et france
par exemple la loi pénale la loi pénale
a offert aux juges des sentiers immense
on pense par exemple au délit de
harcèlement sexuel
il a été aujourd'hui ramené dans une
expression qui respecte l express
principe de spécialité mais je pense à
un autre délire qui concerne plus
spécialement les hommes politiques que
le délit d'ingérence
quand on pense aux au concept d'intérêt
la cour de cassation va jusqu'à dire
l'intérêt affectif mais l'intérêt
effectif peut aller non seulement de la
femme légitime mais à l'ancienne
maîtresse ou encore aux cousins ou
petits cousins qu'on ignorait c'est à
dire que les concepts qui sont utilisés
sont des concepts que le législateur
prend à termes généraux sans respecter
la destination de la loi alors ma
conclusion lé recco fond quand on
réfléchit sur l'application de la loi on
s'interroge sur le point de savoir si le
législateur qui a fait la loi
est ce que en définitive et cette loi
est applicable
est ce que ne dépend pas du décret pour
avoir soit beau pour que la loi puisse
effectivement recevoir son efficacité et
certains auteurs avaient indiqué que
vous pouvez imaginer que l'absence de
décret était une volonté de réduire le
rôle du parlement je pense pas que le
problème soit posée aujourd'hui cette
façon je pense qu'en fait le problème
est que la loi aujourd'hui elle est
confrontée à d'autres sources normative
je les vois qui fit que la source
normative du juge français mais
également les droits européens et la
jurisprudence communautaire c'est à dire
que la part de la loi est de plus en
plus faibles et surtout la loi est
arbitré passe d'autres qui eux vont
donner la véritable application qu'il
sera pas celle qu'a voulu législateur
voilà pourquoi en tant qu'avocat je
pense que nous entrons dans une société
qui mériterait de réfléchir sur ces
concepts
c'est à dire qu'il faut que la loi
redevienne la loi on en revienne aux
principes du décalogue et que en
définitive le bon sens puissent
prévaloir la sécurité juridique la
compétitivité puisqu'on en parle
aujourd'hui ça fait partie des principes
de lisibilité de sécurité affirmé par la
convention européenne des roms
merci monsieur le bâtonnier donc on va
passer justement à la discussion plus
précis là-dessus mais dans la prochaine
de séquences plus généralisée propos je
veux juste relevé que nous nous sommes
dans un discours apparemment uniforme
c'est à dire d'un côté les maires qui
disent c'est le préfet qui fait les qui
fait finalement la loire et puis les
avocats qui nous disent c'est le juge
qui fait la loi
et en même temps dans les solutions il
ya des solutions qui apparaissent
contradictoires où on est mais les
grands principes
on s'en tient là c'est ce que disait
didier mathus et à ce moment là la
précision va être donné un autre et on
vous dira c'est les autres qui font la
loi
ou on est trop précis et on nous dira
que en rentrant dans ces précisions on
complexifie et on pousse par près
presque fait de dominos ceux qui font
les décrets et circulaires à être encore
plus précis et a rajouté de la norme
bien donc j'ai essayé de comprendre ce
qui se dégage de là et dans un propos
qui apparaît simple bon sens vous avez
dit il ya beaucoup plus de complexité et
de choses a tranché en tous les cas
merci pour vos interventions
est ce qu'il y à sur cette séquence
monsieur y est monsieur le président je
voudrais quand même rappeler qu'il ya
quand même normalement on n constitution
avec des normes juridiques un article 34
cas du domaine de la loi
il ya du domaine du règlement on ne
respecte plus depuis très longtemps
les professeurs de droit je sais plus
s'il enseigne encore la différence parce
que ça sert à rien on est au fait
n'importe quoi au fait des débats des
lois qui sont des circulaires et puis
aux héros comme on veut alors moi ce qui
me préoccupe c'est c'est moi aussi je
suis mère manquant j'ai aussi un peu
plus mesdames d'un village le voit bien
les difficultés pour appliquer par
exemple la loi sur l'accessibilité des
handicapés dans d'autres pays on
applique vraiment des règles en matière
d'accessibilité il ya des pays qui sont
très en avance par rapport à nous ils
ont beaucoup moins de lois c'est bizarre
hein ce qu'ils font du bon sens et puis
les commissions d'accessibilité des
préfectures ne sont pas aussi rigide
parfois mais parce qu'il ya des textes
alors nous on fait des tests on fabrique
des textes et une rajoute alors chacun
en rajoute un petit peu je parle pas les
normes incendie je connais ça par coeur
depuis
j'essaie de pratiquer même dans ma
profession donc mais c'est pas du tout
pareil que ce que ce qu'on dit c'est ces
2 2 à 2 deux questions différentes
ce que dit le maire enfin le
représentant des verts les usagers et ce
que disent les praticiens du droit
alors là c'est bon on connaît la
propension d'une chambre de la cour de
cassation à faire sa propre loi
enfin je peux le dire voire plus
j'errais jamais dans cette chambre alors
donc je peux être tranquille
mais le plus intéressant c'est ce qu'a
dit le bâtonnier watier à mon avis c'est
les télescopages des différentes
juridictions
la cour de cassation s'appuyant sur la
jurisprudence parfois de luxembourg mais
aussi de strasbourg comme il fait le
contrôle de conventionnalité ça rentre
elle s'arrange aujourd'hui très bien et
c'est vrai qu'on a un vrai problème
bravo pour les avocats c'est formidable
franchement c'est des sources de
contentieux est extraordinaire je mets
moi par contre je dirais toujours que
depuis toujours il ya quand même eu à
partir de loi dès construction
jurisprudentielle
et c'est pas normal ce que veuillez
m'excuser même si petit à petit on se
détourne de sa toute la responsabilité
civile a été construite de manière
jurisprudentielle faut-il s'en plaindre
vous faut-il s'en féliciter bois je m'en
féliciterais plus tôt et petit à petit
d'ailleurs les le législateur commence à
attaquer ce bloc et vouloir faire des
lois surtout regarder comment la traiter
déjà le 13 186 le procès du code civil
on en a rajouté plein plein plein plein
avance était lisible y avait le juré de
prudence quand la jurisprudence est
claire ce qui est gênant c'est que quand
le législateur niveau de jurisprudence
ne me plaît pas en tant que législateur
et que je vais affirmé un certain nombre
de choses que malgré ça le le juge
continue a interprété par des voies
détournées sas estime choc mais quand
même
heureusement heureusement qu'il y a
quand même de grands blocs qui
son du droit jurisprudentiel à condition
qu'ils soient stables il peut évoluer
mais à condition qu'il soit stable donc
je serai plus nuancé parce que quand
même la jurisprudence c'est aussi une
source du droit
veuillez m'excuser ç'a toujours été une
source du droit le tout c'est notre
équilibre
mais vous voyez encore que ce qui est
apparaît simple bon sens vous avez
commencé comme ça en disant il ya la
constitution qu en gros tout est clair
et puis ensuite l'exemple que vous
donnez sur le luxembourg dans la
constitution les traiter les traitait
son supérieur à la loi d'où coupe c'est
ce qu'il y ait ben oui c'est la coupe
non mais je jeu de critiques rien je
relève que dans cette complexité il y à
des sujets que nous devons traiter et
mais c'est pas seulement en louvoyant
coup ou qu'on s'en sort monsieur richard
houis ce président je crois qu'on a deux
approches qui sont se complète sans
doute ce n'est pas tout à fait
convergentes salissantes du rôle de la
jurisprudence je veux dire j'ai prouvé
petite gêne à ce qu' il n'y a personne
ici qui puisse commenter ans minimum de
solidarité avec la cour de cassation six
qui avaient été mises en cause sont
assez critiques avaient émané du conseil
d'état j'aime linke au moins une
personne dans la salle qui aurait pu
argumenter un peu dans le cas où nous
sommes il n'y a pas de place pour le
droit de réponse comme j'ai ensuite il
faut qu'on s'habitue
depuis une petite soixantaine d'années à
ce que le parlement soit dans l'état de
droit et pas au dessus il ya une
constitution
il ya un contrôle de constitutionnalité
la france a souscrit des engagements
internationaux est entrée dans l'union
européenne il est donc normal que des
normes supérieures s'impose à la loi ap
à découvrir ça donc moi je veux je ne me
hasarde pas à commenter les critiques
qui ont été faites contre la cour de
cassation
en revanche sur la question la
prolifération normative qu'évoquer
didier de malthus moi je pars d'un
constat assez simple en général quand
une norme devient impératif c'est
quelqu'un l'a voulu est ce que quelqu'un
peut être une institution publique
ça peut aussi être un groupe d'intérêts
privés de deux natures différentes soit
les intérêts purement économiques soient
des intérêts d'affirmations d'opinion à
dire les choses gentiment et nous
observons de plus en plus ça y'a aucun
loot 7 en croissance le fait d'obtenir
une norme dont on a la paternité dont on
a là la récompense sur toutes les formes
devient un enjeu de combat et il ya un
vrai sujet de la capacité du législateur
à réagir à ces attitudes de combat parce
que malheureusement plus d'un
législateur se fait l'auxiliaire de ses
concurrents de normes nouvelles
donc ça je pense est un sujet sur lequel
il faut qu'on approfondisse un peu aucun
de ces textes absurdes m'est arrivé par
l'observation opération du saint-esprit
a toujours été voulu par quelqu'un je
pense s'était dit par un intervenant que
l'invasion du pénal a considérablement
aggravé les choses
quoi donc ma vie professionnelle et
publique
j'ai vu la différence par exemple dans
les cabinets entre avant et après la
sphère du sens à ce que les membres du
gouvernement concernés par la sphère du
sang ont été formellement déclaré en
tout cas pour 1 entre eux coupable sans
être sanctionné les membres de cabinets
avec les directeurs de service sont
allés en correctionnelle et ont eu de la
prison avec sursis
ça fait une différence là encore
quelqu'un qui gagne le fait d'emmener un
concurrent en adversaire au pénal est en
soi une victoire narcissique et c'est
évidemment un sujet médiatique qui
rebondit à loisir mais encore il ya des
gens qui ont intérêt à ça et les gens
qui ont intérêt à les aider et la partie
n'est pas égal
enfin faut bien que nous fassions un peu
notre examen de réalité nous vivons
depuis 60 ans avec le principe la santé
n'a pas de prix
on a vu ce que ça donnait maintenant on
vit avec le principe
la sécurité ça n'a pas de prix et
l'environnement ça n'a pas de prix
ceux-ci déclenchent des situations de
contres priorité de dépassement des
limites que plus personne n'arrive à
gérer et évidemment les deux choses dire
la recherche de reconnaissance ou de
satisfaction économique et ses principes
qui deviennent ingérables dans la vie
publique montrent un petit rapport entre
eux oui motionnaire alors il veut c'est
le président je vais juste pour qu'ils
aient aucune frustration qu'ils puissent
installer
vous avez remarqué
un temps le débat après chaque séquence
qui bon donc vous parler si d'autres
veulent parler jeudi c'est fini pour
cette séquence ils seront sûr la
deuxième voire la troisième il a encore
du temps devant nous avoue bien monsieur
le président maintenant pas juriste
c'est parfait je vais pouvoir poser donc
des questions toutes simples existent on
ou encore vous qui avez été à
l'initiative de cette commission pour
donner aux législateurs une position
plus forte par rapport à l'exécutif et
notamment en suivant l'application des
lois
on est en train de se rendre compte que
finalement le législateur est pris
aujourd'hui entre le marteau et
l'enclume entre d'une part pouvoir
exécutif qui est relié sous la vème
république
les pouvoirs qu'on pouvait avoir sous la
ivème on sait pourquoi on en a vu les
conséquences positives mais peut-être
aussi quelques-unes de négatives et
maintenant on découvre que l'autorité
judiciaire en fait concrètement est vrai
pouvoir judiciaire s'est pas inscrit
comme ça dans la constitution a
connaissance mais ont des cours en
entendant les spécialistes du droit
si tant est qu'on ne sache pas qu'il y a
effectivement une création
alors vous avez raison cher collègue ne
nous élevons pas systématiquement contre
tout jurisprudence le droit
administratif qui est quelque chose de
particulièrement passionnant intéressant
en france et de création
jurisprudentielle essentiellement donc
c'est pas contre la jurisprudence qu'il
faut se lever c'est pas ça parce que la
question
1c existants nous encore deuxième
question qui va avec c'est dans quelle
démocratie sauf nous pour moi la
question est là maintenant elle est que
les gens qui sont élus vous êtes élu je
suis et j'ai des comptes à rendre
nous nous avons des comptes à rendre et
la démocratie montesquieu à 10 et des
pouvoirs et des contre-pouvoirs
mais politiques ont beau quelques
pouvoirs et beaucoup de contre-pouvoir
ansade aperçoit tous les jours mais si
contrairement à la jurisprudence qui
innove qui invente mais qui ne va pas
contre le législateur on trouve ce qu'on
vient d'entendre ici c'est à dire que
quand nous nous faisons un texte clair
le juge lui décide de faire autre chose
où est le contre-pouvoir qui
permettraient de rétablir justement une
certaine sécurité juridique que je dirai
pas ce que le législateur a voulu faire
quelque chose
donc moi je pose la question c'est quoi
notre démocratie aujourd'hui et où
va-t-on et comment on y va voilà donc
c'est quelque chose de plus fondamental
peut-être encore une fois que la
jurisprudence
merci bien pour un pour aller sur cette
deuxième séquence je crois que des
sciences ont bien fait parce que là la
responsabilité on dit le juge le préfet
tout ils vont pouvoir en tous les cas le
préfet et préfet parler mais j'ai été
saisie par des juges qui me disait ce
serait pas mal que vous évaluez les lois
qui touchent à nos noms l'ensemble de
loi qui se sont succédés notamment sur
sur le pénitentiaire et d'autres lois
peines plancher ensuite il ya eu du bon
c'est à des moments nous on a un
problème c'est que quand vous légiférez
tous les ans sur les mêmes sujets sans
évaluer les autres ce qui a été fait
avant on a des jugements à rendre nous
appuyons sur les textes de loi qui se
contredisent disent pas la même faune
c'est rare mais ça arrive bien donc qui
a la responsabilité du législateur a
légiféré probablement de façon plus
claire et de façon disons et c'est ce
qu'on a souvent dit dans notre
commission avant de légiférer regarder
ce qui existe avant un et ça c'est notre
responsabilité pour pas que donc on est
tous dans des responsabilités à charge a
dit certain divertir
monsieur carcassonne des travaux alors
une des ambitions de notre commission et
de passer du contrôle de la publication
des textes réglementaires d'application
qui est la première démarche au contrôle
de cette application elle-même deuxième
démarche
ce qui débouche évidemment sur un
travail d'évaluation troisième les
marches on essaye de le décor à trois
démarches de du contrôle de
l'application des lois
comment concevez-vous l'articulation
entre ces trois moments le travail
d'évaluation buts souvent sur l'absence
de critères permettant de mesurer si la
loi a bien répondu aux objectifs que
s'était assigné le législateur en la
votant quelles améliorations ou les
injurier vous dans cette voie par
exemple en en mieux exploitable est une
impasse et sait comment voyez-vous
l'amélioration des problématiques que je
viens de vous poser si monsieur le
président
vous avez entendu que moi la radio hier
que l'on avait découvert un monsieur qui
avait 11 grammes d'alcool dans le sang
et je pense que la france à 11 grammes
de normes l'encens et que toutes les
capacités d'absorption rationnelle sont
largement dépassées que n'importe quel
autre pays aurait déjà fait un ictus ou
une apoplexie et que chez nous on a
l'impression qu'on continue à pouvoir en
déverser comme ça c'est une situation
absolument absolument dramatique aucune
entité ne peut absorber plus de matière
que cette capacité ne le lui permet et
je pense qu'en france la dose est très
largement dépassé que nous vivons dans
un système complètement fou aujourd'hui
où pour diverses raisons qui ont été
très très bien analysé déjà qu'ils
seront encore on continue à ajouter des
normes à des normes avec une perte de
sens totalement concerné j'entendais
didier mathus se plaindre à juste titre
de ce que la norme va mal je le rassure
le contrôle de légalité va à peu près
aussi mal armé simplement on touche là
absolument à l'absurde ont fait
d'énormes mais ensuite on se soucie
assez peu de l'heureux l'application de
le respect de leur exécution ou alors on
s'en remet à l'arme fatale du juge pénal
qui sera là pour ramasser tous les
malheureux qui auront manqué à une norme
même là même la plus loufoque d'entre
elles bon sur les temps je ne vais pas
poursuivre plus longtemps sur ce sur
selon l'amm un taux qui partageait
depuis des années le rab le rapport du
conseil d'état sur la loi bavarde n'est
pas n'est pas frais et pourtant il est
toujours active enfin il est toujours
il conserve toute son actualité donc les
le constat n'appelle absolument pas de
développement et je ne vais pas perdre
de temps dessus nous le connaissons tous
il est accablant mais je crois
véritablement qu'aujourd'hui il a
dépassé tout ce que l'on pouvait
imaginer
les causes les causes ici je rejoins
tout à fait ce que disait est ce que
disait alain richard à l'instant je vois
d'ailleurs que dans votre découpage vous
versez si j'ose dire monsieur l'allemand
et monsieur lasvignes dans les
producteurs mais je pense que ce sont
des producteurs souvent à leur corps
défendant
ils ne sont pas les premiers produits
producteurs de normes
ils sont au contraire eux ceux sur
lesquels tombent en fin de parcours
l'obligation d'avoir remplir des pages
uniquement parce que d'autres ont décidé
qu'il le fallait
d'où vient d'où vient cette cette
profusion de textes de toutes sortes de
phénomènes
je me devais écrit il ya quelques années
que tout sujet du 20h fait virtuellement
une loi hélas c'est ça se confirme
quotidiennement il y à une fabrication
de normes qui ne correspond même pas une
demande mais à un pari sur le fait
qu'une demande pourrait exister c'est
quand je dis que tout sujet du 21
février actuellement une loi le pari il
est là on sait très bien que la loi n'a
pas vocation à régler quelques problèmes
que ce soit que quoique écrivent le
législateur un chien et le méchant
continuera à mordre et un enfant pourra
toujours se noyé dans une piscine de
même qu'un ascenseur pourra tomber mais
mais on fait une loi parce qu'on se dit
que sinon on pourrait se fait reprocher
de ne pas l'avoir fait que café le
législateur café le législateur donc on
présuppose qu'il y a de la part de
l'opinion publique
une espèce de revendications
légistatives âpre et permanente que à ma
connaissance personne ne s'est jamais
préoccupé de vérifier accessoirement
lorsque l'on est confronté à une demande
déraisonnable de l'opinion publique
eh bien il me semble que dans un système
démocratique la responsabilité des
politiques
et d'expliquer que cette demande est
déraisonnable ce n'est pas parce que 60
% des français sont favorables la
publication du patrimoine des ministres
que c'est une bonne mesure et je pense
qu'il serait peut-être plus digne
d'expliquer pourquoi c'est une
inepte que de dire 60 % des français
sont pour donc il faut qu'on le fasse à
partir de là il y à ces demandes
collectives y nommer non identifiés
présumé qui est déjà génératrice d'un
nombre phénoménal de normes à ses
demandes
hinault mais s'ajoute la profusion de la
demande nommé et là je renvoie à ce que
disait alain richard à l'instant toute
sorte de lobby de contre lobby voire de
services administratifs qui pour se
faciliter la vie considère que pour
régler tel ou tel problème ce serait
bien d'avoir un article 10 latif et tout
ça alimente la profusion
partant de là quelle réponse sans doute
parce que j'ai été nourri au lait de la
vème république
je me dis que faute de mieux
faute de mieux les les procédures sont
quand même utile les procédures sont
utiles et qu'on peut souvent trouvés
dans des procédures des réponses que
l'on ne peut pas trouver ailleurs les
procédures sont souvent un substitut
d'ailleurs extrêmement efficace ou en
tout cas utile à la trophy de la volonté
politique parce que il ne suffit pas de
de se tourner vers la polo volonté
politique ambiance et ça n'est qu'une
question de volonté
le gouvernement a qu'à faire moins de
projets de loi oui bon on sait tous dans
pêche que comme par hasard tous les
gouvernements continuent à faire autant
de projets dois donc me dit que les
procédures peuvent parfois aider à faire
ce à quoi la la volonté ne suffit pas
alors que peut-on faire du point de vue
des procédures je crois qu'il ya des
choses qui pourraient être très utiles
d'abord je tiens à le dire et ce n'est
pas par eux flagornerie dû à votre
invitation mais je considère que la
commission que vous présidez est en soi
un progrès considérable que de simples
simplement et évidemment c'est une mine
pour les enseignants chercheurs dans
dont je suis simplement disposer
d'instruments très précis sur la
fabrication de la norme réglementaire
suivant ou ne suivant pas la fabrication
la norme législative est déjà un
enseignement très éclairant et lorsque
l'on découvre que des lois
peuvent rester dix ans sans que les
mesures d'application ne soit adoptée on
se dit que il ya vraiment quelque chose
d'anormal de presque aussi anormal que
quand on sait qu'une loi
constitutionnelle adoptée en 2007 n'a
toujours pas bénéficier de la loi
organique qu'elle prévoit bien donc en
soi le fait que des parlementaires
consacrent une partie de leur temps à
contrôler l'existence des mises en
oeuvre législative réglementaire pardon
et au passage à évaluer a commencé à
évaluer la pertinence de la loi on se
dit donc un premier progrès effet si
j'étais méchant je dirais que le progrès
est double d'une part on acquiert des
connaissances supplémentaires et d'autre
part le temps qu'ils consacrent à ça il
ne le consacre pas légiférer c'est
toujours ça de gagné malheureusement
d'autres le font à leur place le rêve le
rêve absolu à mes yeux mais ça c'est un
fantasme et il faut vraiment être un
universitaire pour y songer
ce serait que un jour un président de la
république et le courage de déclarer un
moratoire législative d'un an
on ne fait pas de loi vous rendez compte
que ce serait merveilleux
je ne suis pas sûr que le pays réel plus
mal je pense en revanche qu'il pourrait
éventuellement allé sensiblement mieux
et je n'exclus même pas que beaucoup de
français applaudissent applaudissent à
cette idée mais plus sérieusement j'ai
fondé comme beaucoup de grands espoirs
sur les études d'impact mais je trouve
et je l' ai dit à l'époque que la
révision 2008 si elle présente à mes
yeux de très très grande vertu a
néanmoins souffert de ce que un certain
nombre de demi mesures ont été adoptées
à l'égard de mesures qui dont le
principe était excellent je vais donner
deux exemples le délai minimum qui doit
séparer le dépôt d'un projet de ceux du
début de sa discussion bien au comité
balladur
moi j'avais commencé par proposer trois
mois au bas du nom c'est quand même
excessif on était arrivé à 2 bon
finalement dans le projet et à la
demande du gouvernement c'est devenu six
semaines c'est mieux que rien enfin six
semaines franchement ça aurait été 8 de
deux ou trois mois ça ne fait de mal à
personne mais on a ajouté
que évidemment ce délai ne s'appliquait
pas si le texte était déclarée enfin
faisait l'objet de la procédure
accélérée le résultat qui était
prévisible s'est produit depuis le début
de cette législature
il n'y a pratiquement rien en face il ya
eu un petit changement récent il ya eu
au début que que des textes soumet la
procédure accélérée que des textes
soumis aux procédures accélérées ce qui
fait que le remède s'est révélée pire
que le mal
uniquement parce que le remède a été mal
conçue le délai minimum paraissait
l'expertisé j'avais fait une proposition
dont je reconnais qu'elle était un peu
novatrice mais dont je persiste à penser
qu'elle est frappé au coin du bon sens
qui consistait à dire qu' il ne pouvait
être fait observer on ne pouvait éviter
ce délai minimal qu'avec l'accord de
l'opposition et je suis désolé de dire
que ça me paraît beaucoup plus
raisonnables jamais l'opposition ne
s'opposera à l'urgence d'un texte
véritablement urgent jamais le
gouvernement ne demandera l'opposition
d'accepter l'urgence d'un texte il n'est
pas urgent et je trouve que ce serait un
pouvoir qui serait bien plus bien mieux
placé entre les mains de l'opposition
qu'entre les mains comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
des conférences des présidents qui
évidemment non non jamais fait usage n
en feront jamais usage même si une fois
elles ont menacé qu'elle pourrait
éventuellement le faire
selon le délai minimum à condition
qu'ils soient suffisamment long entre le
dépôt examen permet de faire quelque
chose qui est effectivement assez fruste
qui consiste à réfléchir à l'utilité de
la loi évidemment c'est passé de mode
mais quand même on peut penser que ça ne
manque pas tout à fait l'utilité le
deuxième exemple qui est d'ailleurs
directement lié à celui ci c'est l'étude
d'impact comme je les dis je nourrissais
beaucoup d'espoir pour l'étude d'impact
et je pense d'ailleurs que les études
d'impact ont d'ores et déjà rendu des
services réels même s'ils sont encore
assez loin selon moi de ce qu'il
pourrait apporter le rêve le rêve que je
nourris delà de la bonne discussion
législative serait celle qui précisément
aurait comme objet de commencer par une
discussion sur l'étude d'impact et pas
sur la loi pas sur le projet pas sur le
projet c'est le système qui marche somme
toute assez bien en grande bretagne avec
le système des livres blancs livre vert
ça mais on commence par parler de
l'étude d'impact
voilà il y a
blême quelles sont les données du
problème mettons nous d'accord sur les
faits envisageons ensuite les remèdes et
enfin si ces remèdes passe par la loi
quel type de lois faut-il faire c'est à
dire exactement le contenu de l'étude
d'impact
je suis convaincu que tout changerait
dans la fabrication des normes si l'on
pouvait imaginer
enfin c'est très facile à imaginer mais
si on pouvait mettre en oeuvre une
procédure dans laquelle on commençait
par avoir une sorte de discussion
générale sur l'étude d'impact
une fois encore pas sur le projet de loi
et puis une semaine deux semaines trois
semaines plus tard un mois plus tard peu
importe on commence éclairé par cette
discussion générale l'examen du projet
de loi
je gage qu'un nombre très substantiel de
projet de loi ne verrez plus le jour
disparaîtrait ou en tout cas sûre et
modifier de manière sans doute beaucoup
plus éclairés qu'ils ne sont aujourd'hui
de sorte que tout le reste de la
question vous est posée monsieur le
président s'en déduit lorsque vous dites
à juste titre qu'il faut s'intéresser et
vous le faites à la sortie des textes
réglementaires
mais ensuite à la performance de la loi
et bien tout devient beaucoup plus
simple parce que la performance de la
loi sera là jugés sur des critères
extrêmement clair ce qu'une véritable
discussion sur l'étude d'impact aura
permis d'identifier ces cette discussion
elle même qui dira voilà ce que seront
les critères de la réussite
à partir du moment où les critères de la
réussite les critères de la performance
législatives seront discutées
contradictoirement et déterminé le
travail d'évaluation ex post s'en trouve
extraordinairement facilité
extraordinairement clarifier au lieu que
comme chacun sait on fait des lois dans
la précipitation donc on les fait mal on
s'avise qu'elles sont mal faites donc on
les refait on les refait dans la
précipitation donc on les refait mal et
ainsi le serpent se serre la queue et on
atteint les 11 g auquel nous sommes déjà
situé merci l'exemple avant de
presque d'école que kim est posée
aujourd'hui nous avons fait une
évaluation un rapport sur la loi lru ça
dans les universités arrive une nouvelle
loi
j'ai demandé bien entendu que soit
inscrite à l'ordre du jour le rapport
qui est excellent avant on me dit mais
ça va se percutent et c'est les mêmes
débats donc mais quel sens ça aurait de
discuter la loi précédente
après la loi que nous allons élaborer
bon donc le fait même qu'on puisse poser
la question montre encore que la
question d'évaluation avant sur les lois
qui régissent l'université avant de re
légiférer sur l'université nous on
considère que c'est inutile
en tous les cas des questions d'agenda
peuvent primer sur le second sens là et
on essaie dans cette commission de
d'alimenter une autre culture celle
celle de l'exigence du contrôle de
l'application alors pour cela j'ai voulu
que notre débat soit soit éclairé aussi
par les expériences ailleurs regardant
dehors de nos frontières sur la question
de l'application des lois
car il y a deux
d des expériences très diverses et en
même temps des cultures politiques ou où
c'est au coeur vous disposez madame
céline kaufmann de données comparatives
sur le thème de l'application des lois
dans différents pays de l' ocde
comparable à la france
y at il une typologie général des
problèmes qu'elles soulèvent et de la
manière dont les pouvoirs publics qui
répondent et puis aux yeux des grandes
organisations internationales la qualité
du droit et surtout un instrument de
compétitivité et d'attractivité
économique ce sont comme ça que c'est
c'est aborder existe-t-il un classement
international dans ce domaine
et s'il n'y en a pas ou placeriez vous
la france par rapport à ses grands
partenaires de l'union européenne
question très facile mais merci monsieur
le président merci aussi à nathalie
tignol pour et aux organisateurs pour
cette opportunité de présenter le
travail de l' ocde effectivement ce que
je vais faire c'est vous donnez un peu
la perspective internationale sur ce
sujet non seulement la perspective est
international mais étant une économiste
et une juriste une perspective qui
englobe les aspects des aspects
économiques
donc moi je travaille au sein de la
division de la politique réglementaire
de l' ocde qui sert le comité de la
politique réglementaire donc un comité
qui a rassemblé 34 pays de l'osce et des
oeufs et dont le mandat est de
développer des outils de collecter des
bonnes pratiques en soutien à une bonne
gouvernance une bonne politique
réglementaire
donc je vais vous en donner un peu les
leçons apprises en dix minutes assez
rapidement d'abord joué je voudrais
commencer par trois points qui sont qui
sont clés qui sont à la fois des
présupposés à ce travail du comité mais
aussi des grandes leçons de ce travail
le premier étant que évidemment il est
possible d'atteindre les objectifs que
se fixent les politiques publiques
objectifs sociaux économiques
environnementaux à un coût moindre
en légiférant mieux en améliorant
le processus de production des normes le
processus réglementaire et c'est
évidemment la base de notre travail et
qui est un accent mis essentiellement
sur la qualité de ce produit de ce
processus de production des lois
beaucoup plus sur la quantité des lois
qui peuvent en sortir au bout cela
demande deuxième point une vision
stratégique et globale du cycle de la
gouvernance réglementaire est là pour
nous et pour les pays en général ça veut
dire trois choses vision stratégique et
globale ça veut dire de l'application
des lois ça veut dire non seulement
regarder le flux de production de normes
mais ça veut dire aussi gérer le stock
de ces normes et les deux vont ensemble
deuxièmement approche globale ça veut
dire avoir une approche globale du cycle
de la production des lois de la
production même des lois jusqu'à leur
mise en oeuvre et leur révision
donc c'est une approche vraiment très
très globale et troisièmement et de
façon très importante et ça a déjà été
soulevé une approche globale pour nous
ça veut dire pas seulement une approche
juridique de la loi mais une approche en
termes d'impact sur la société donc
impacts économiques sociaux et
environnementaux
et pour cela ces points-là et ses
objectifs des pays se sont traduit très
concrètement dans les pays ocde par la
mise en place d'une certaine
architecture institutionnelle pour
favoriser cette approche globale et la
rendre beaucoup plus automatiques mais
aussi ça s'est traduit par l'adoption
d'un certain nombre de d'outils de
gestion de la régulation on en a parlé
des jades inquiets les études d'impact
et je vais revenir sur ça mais il ya
aussi d'autres outils de deux
consultations de transparence et c'est
sûr sûr sûr les normes et qui sont des
outils dans les mains du du pouvoir
exécutif notamment pour améliorer le
système réglementaire en termes
d'architecturé institutionnel ce que
l'on a vu dans les pays d'auch s'est
dernièrement dans les dix ont dans les
20 dernières années c'est la mise en
place d'un organisme de supervision
la politique réglementaire et de la
gouvernance réglementaire au sein de
l'exécutif
en général ça a commencé aux états unis
par la mise en place de ce qu'on appelle
avoir acquis officer d'information
annuel de la cuy à fès au sein de ompi
office of management and budget qui
était vraiment au centre du gouvernement
et a un mandat très clair en soutien à
la petite politique réglementaire et
aujourd'hui on voit ce mécanisme la qui
s'est développée dans tous les pays de
l' ocde en france l'équivalent serait
probablement le secrétariat
le secrétariat général du gouvernement
qui jouerait ce rôle là mais ce qu'on
voit plus récemment et qui a une
tendance est en train de se développer
depuis disons 5 6 ans c'est le
développement d'institutions
indépendantes de l'exécutif mandaté par
l'exécutif et qui fait un retour sur la
politique réglementaire et notamment sur
la façon dont l'exécutif effectué ces
évaluations d'impact
c'est le cas notamment en allemagne mais
c'est aussi le cas au royaume uni en
république tchèque en allemagne
ça s'appelle le conseil de contrôle
réglementaire qui a été notamment établi
en 2006 et qui reçoit les projets de loi
des ministères et qui détermine si
l'évaluation des coûts et les choix de
mesures qui ont été prises sont
appropriée au regard des objectifs de
politique publique et au regard des
ressources des ressources disponibles
la dernière institution que je voudrais
mentionner parce que c'est une
institution clé en australie c'est la
productivité comme un chien qui est de
nouveau une institution indépendante
mandatée par le gouvernement pour faire
un retour non pas sur des projets de loi
particulier mais sur la politique
réglementaire général du gouvernement
de façon tout à fait indépendante après
le gouvernement met en oeuvre ne met pas
en oeuvre mais tous les rapports de la
productivité commission sont son public
sont en ligne et
elle fait des retours sur la politique
réglementaire ou sur des réformes
réglementaires particulières
ça c'est le premier point une
architecture institutionnelle qui se met
en place dans les pays de l' ocde
le deuxième point c'est en plus de cet
arsenal institutionnelle depuis une
vingtaine d'années les pays se sont
évidemment dotée d'outils de gestion
réglementaire la panoplie de bonne de
ces outils est large allant des
mécanismes de consultation aux analyses
d'impact exempté et ex post
ce que l'on voit sur les analyses
d'impact et on a commencé cette
discussion là c'est que dans la plupart
des pays ocde
ça reste un exercice largement formelle
parce qu'on appelle un exercice de types
de boxe pour montrer qu'il a été fait
mais qui ne va pas forcément dans les
détails et en profondeur et une preuve
de cela c'est que à peine la moitié des
pays de l' ocde donc en gros vous avez
tous les pays de ces deux les 34 qui ont
adopté ces évaluations d'impact
il y a à peine la moitié qui fait un
retour si sur le fait que cette
évaluation d'impact a suivi ou non les
critères d'élaboration de ces
évaluations d'impact et vous avez
seulement quatre ou cinq pays qui
regarde si effectivement le l'analyse
d'impact a un impact sur la façon dont
la loi et déterminé in fine et quatre ou
cinq pays sur 34 ce n'est pas énorme
alors quels sont les les principes clés
pour ses évaluations d'impact pour
lesquels les pays où en général
développer des des principes directeurs
vous avez un exemple qui est celui de la
commission européenne qui viennent juste
de mettre à jour et qui est pour nous et
est un modèle les principes clés c'est
évidemment qu'il ya une vraie analyse
coûts-bénéfices delà du projet de la loi
à venir de la réglementation deuxième
point important c'est que les
alternatives à la halle à la loi soit
considérée de façon sérieuse et donc ça
ça implique évidemment
que cette évaluation soit fait en amont
très en amont
parce que si la loi a déjà été a déjà
été annoncé comme étant une moi de toute
façon les alternatives qui aurait pu
être trouvé son discret mais discrédité
par nature et la troisième le troisième
bons principes disons bonnes pratiques
c'est souvent l'adoption de seuil on ne
peut pas traiter tous les projets de loi
delà de la même façon en termes
d'évaluation est souvent les pays ont
adopté un seuil soit quantitatif comme
les etats-unis qui font d évaluation en
profondeur seulement pour les lois qui
entraîne plus de 100 millions de dollars
d'impact en terme de coût ou de
bénéfices mais d'autres pays ont des des
seuils qui sont un mélange qualitatifs
et quantitatifs comme c'est le cas au
royaume uni la deuxième chose très
importante c'est on a commencé aussi à
en parler c'est la prise en compte de la
mise en oeuvre
effectivement dès la production
réglementaire et dans ce domaine il ya
un pays qui a été novateur et ce sont
les pays bas qui ont par le biais de ce
qu'ils appellent ce qu'ils ont appelé
leur impact assessment intégrer des
l'évaluation d'impact les impacts en
termes est-ce applicable à quel coût
sous quelles conditions
donc dès l'évaluation d'impact vous avez
cet exercice de regarder l'application
de la loi qui est à une vérification de
réalité de réalisme assez assez assez
forte
quel est le rôle du parlement et je
finirai sûr ça quel est le rôle du
parlement dans cette dent dans cette
chaîne dans cette chaîne de gouvernance
réglementaire alors le parlement
évidemment un rôle essentiel à jouer
pour s'assurer de la qualité des
évaluations exemptés ce que nous on
appelle et ria et pour cela un exemple
intéressant qui a déjà été mentionné
c'est l'exemple de de la stricte unis
unit au royaume uni qui a le pouvoir
effectivement doré
gires très fortement sur les évaluations
d'impact qui sont soumises au parlement
et qui a aussi le pouvoir de demander
des informations supplémentaires au cas
où ces évaluations serait incomplète
c'est une unité un service technique
établie au sein du parlement qui a cette
vocation là le parlement dans les pays
de l' ocde a aussi très souvent un rôle
important à jouer sur et surtout en
général un rôle à jouer sur tout ce qui
est évaluation ex post et donc
évaluation de la mise en oeuvre des lois
et de leur impact et sur ça on est en
train de commencer avec un certain à
travailler avec un certain nombre de
parlements nos clients habituels sont en
général les pouvoirs exécutifs les
ministères mais là on est en train de
commencer à travailler avec eux les
parlements et notamment deux a regardé
ses unités parlementaires qui sont en
train de se développer qui ont en charge
l'évaluation ex post de l'application
des lois comme vous avez par exemple le
cas en suisse avec le contrôle
parlementaire de l'administration
comme vous avez de nouveau au royaume
uni où vous avez aussi en suède qui est
une unité d'évaluation et de recherche
pour l'instant très très honnêtement les
mandats les structures de gouvernance et
et institutionnels de ses différentes
unités sont vraiment très diverses
c'est souvent des unités petites la plus
grosse pour l'instant que l'on connaît
c'est justement l'aspect qui nous unit
au royaume uni qui fait à peu près 20
personnes ce qui se dégage très
fortement c'est ces deux choses déjà
l'indépendance de ces deux de ses unités
au sein au sein du parlement
ce sont des unités techniques dont les
membres doivent être neutres
politiquement pour une obligation
disons d'impartialité et la deuxième
grande leçon de ce que l'on peut tirer
c'est le fait que quoi qu'il arrive ces
unités n'auront jamais suffisamment de
ressources pour couvrir le champ très
vaste de l'évaluation est donc ce que
l'on voit c'est qu'elle évidemment
s'associe avec des bureaux de recherche
avec potentiellement les organismes
d'audit pour pour pour faire ces
évaluations et que tout n'est pas
intégrée au sein du parlement
je m'arrêterai là merci c'est je vais
proposer tout de suite que on est la
discussion générale après les
interventions du préfet monsieur le
secrétaire général ce que là vous êtes
de fait une très bonne transition parce
qu'on était sur l'application de la loi
le problème qui s'est posé à chaque fois
c'est que nous si nous avons créé cette
commission au sein du sénat c'est que
nous avons près encore plus qu'avant au
pied de la lettre ce qui est dans la
constitution et dans la modification
d'un constitutionnel c'est que nous le
législateur fait la loi et contrôler
l'exécutif et le problème c'est que
toutes les évaluations les étudiants pas
acté tout ce dont on parle concret est
fait par l'exécutif est commandée par
l'exécutif donc c'est l'exécutif qui
commande le contrôle et nous n'avons pas
nous aujourd'hui les moyens autonomes du
parlement ni les vins dont vous parlez
ni les capacités de commandes d'études
extérieurs à la hauteur du pack d'avants
rien puisque on travaille tous les cas
nous n'avons pas les moyens tous les cas
il peut y avoir dans la démocratie
américaine pour que le parlement puisse
contrôler l'exécutif telle qu'on
pourrait le souhaiter
voilà donc je j'introduis cela qui est
souvent venu on déballe j'ai maintenant
sénateur qui a démissionné de cette
commission dans une lettre il me disait
ça le le c'est pas bien démissionner
d'un combat mais en tous les cas le
sujet là c'est que nous sommes dans un
exercice qui est plus de révélateur
faire que les commissions sur le fond
sont aussi ce rôle parce que c'est un
rôle mais il y a aujourd'hui un vrai
sujet si on veut évaluer comme on le
fait à chaque fois on a fait
10 évaluation doit au moins aujourd'hui
avec des moyens autonomes
le fait même de pouvoir commander une
étude vidre le budget de ma commission
ou en un coup il aurait pas d'évaluation
voilà donc c'est un sujet je vais aussi
sur la table mais on va tout de suite
écoutez monsieur le préfet didier
lallement secrétaire général du
ministère de l'intérieur
et il y aura une conclusion pour les
intervenants après il y aura un échange
de monsieur la ligue à vous et merci
monsieur le président alors
effectivement vous m'avez invité au
titre producteur de normes alors
j'imagine que votre invitation concerne
en règle générale les administrations ou
fait l'honneur de représenter ici en
compagnie serge s wing d'une façon
peut-être plus générale les ministères
alors sommes nous des producteurs de
normes
oui à l'évidence encore que j'observe
que les stratégies ministériels sont
très différentes les unes des autres
j'ai connu des ministères faible qui
avaient des stratégies de production de
la norme dite de contournement par
rapport au niveau national s'adressant
au niveau communautaire pour que
revienne par l'intermédiaire de
directives ou de règlements des normes
encadrant elle-même et contournant ainsi
le législateur encadrons l'ensemble du
dispositif
je ne citerai pas des ministères mais
j'ai que j'ai contribué à la création
d'un ministère un peu plus vaste sur la
base d'un petit morceau de ministères
qui avait cette stratégie il ya d'autres
ministères quand des stratégies du
duforeau fort plutôt que d'avoir du
faible au fort je parlais de l'écologie
pour que les choses je les dis très
discrètement et hors micro bien
évidemment il ya des ya d'autres
ministères condé stratégique fort aux
forts comme le ministère de l'intérieur
qui finalement or sa partie
collectivités locales produit assez peu
de textes reproduits en matière
électorale bien évidemment sur un
certain nombre de sujets en matière de
programmation mais n'a pas la dimension
productrice
quand un certain nombre d'autres
ministères du mois en direction du
parlement
même si on s'aperçoit que
l'administration elle-même et et
productrice de normes envers elle même
1 on avait recensé avec serge lasvignes
qu'à peu près les préfets devaient
recevoir à peu près 80 mille pages par
an
deux circulaires c'est-à-dire
d'instruction interne de
l'administration
commentant l'ensemble des normes et à
cette occasion en créant un certain
nombre d'autres on n'est d'ailleurs
jamais très bien arriver à hiérarchiser
la production de circulaires on l'avait
envisagé entre les importantes les un
peu moins les pas du tout mais en fait
le système est tel que l' enthousiasme
des chefs de bureau en passant par les
sous directeurs a quelquefois des
directeurs fait que chacun produit
criant les circulaires ont aujourd'hui
une autre traduction par l'intermédiaire
des mails s'aperçoit qu'il ya ce
caractère normatif qui se fait par cet
intermédiaire là et donc nous produisons
beaucoup de normes
alors pour quelle raison fondamentale
puisque c'était un peu ce sur quoi vous
vous interrogez aujourd'hui d'abord la
raison politique a été évoqué tout à
l'heure souvent les ministres demandent
leur loi je suis rarement rencontré le
ministre qui soit très très précis sur
la nature de leurs lois mais souvent ils
demandaient des lois certains même étant
totalement imprécis sur la loi je ne
vais pas donner le nom ici mais il y en
a été directeur des centrales haut débit
de plusieurs législatures
j'ai observé qu'il y avait des commandes
qui étaient pas forcément totalement
finalisé et là ça dépend à qui s'adresse
le ministre quelques administrations
sont porteuses d'une doctrine
extrêmement forte et produisent
systématiquement le même texte j'ai été
dgcl je peux vous dire qu'il ya une
constante dans la dgcl de production du
texte l'on retrouve au fur et à mesure
de la promulgation des lois un peu
toujours le même texte dans le passé
lorsque j'étais déjà celle là longtemps
heureusement tout ça a totalement changé
et les lois de décentralisation qui vont
être proposées n'ont absolument rien à
voir avec tout ça mais quelquefois les
administrations sont assez molle en
termes de doctrine ils ne savent pas
très bien donc s'adressent à leur
clientèle un et la clientèle c'est tout
ce qui de près ou de loin ont quelque
chose à voir avec l'administration et
demandent l'établissement d'une norme
je vous cite par exemple conflit qu'on a
eu très récemment des taxi taxi
demandait que des normes soient
appliquées à un certain nombre de
personnes qui exercent une profession à
peu près similaires mais sans avoir la
licence de taxi
il demandait donc l'établissement des
normes à l'encontre de normes à
l'encontre de cette profession leur
permettant de garantir leur avantage
concurrentiel et du coup demandant à
l'administration par l'intermédiaire de
ses services de police de vérifier
l'application de la norme c'est
extrêmement lourd
mais comme c'était dit tout à l'heure il
ya la force d'une proposition en c'est
très précisément d'où elle vient ne
tombe pas comme c'était dit tout à
l'heure du ciel et il ya une véritable
motivation dans l'obtention de ceux de
ce dispositif est donc là quelques fois
les administrations bassin bible de ses
revendications et les les routes en
quelque sorte par l'intermédiaire des
textes voilà pour ce forum consacré à
l'application des lois si vous souhaitez
le revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
qui reçoit ce soir le sénateur du cantal
et président du groupe rdse ici au sénat
jacques mézard bonne soirée à tous